okay move out
much has been written on the subject of
military history army planners of today
have learned many important principles
of combat operations from military
engagements of the past regardless of
their historical background all Army
shared one common problem how to get the
soldier what he needed to win his battle
when he needed it the military term for
this support is logistics and from
earliest times this problem was of grave
concern to military leaders Alexander
the Great worried about supplying his
expeditionary forces which stretched
from Greece across Asia Minor to
northern India Alexandra's military
campaigns were successful mainly because
he was able to hold the Mediterranean
coasts of Palestine and Syria he used
these coastal areas as supply bases or
dimples as we call them today from these
bases he was able to replenish his
armies with the suppliers had assault
equipment necessary to win victory a
hundred years later in a war against the
Romans Hannibal crossed the Alps from
Spain and faced the similar problem of
maintaining an army stretched far beyond
its borders
unable to obtain mastery of the seas
around southern Italy Hannibal did not
have the advantage of coastal supply
bases supply lines buy land over the
mountains proved inadequate and
eventually a Hannibal's military efforts
in Rome failed Napoleon's armies marched
to disaster when they invaded Russia in
1812 without adequate provision for
maintaining the troops through the
rigors of the Russian winter military
history is full of similar examples
which demonstrate the importance of
logistical support for the fighting man
and the critical role it plays in the
outcome of battle in our own time US
military operations during World War two
included a massive logistical support
effort in both Europe and the Pacific
with large armies fighting on all types
of terrain halfway across the world from
each other logistical planning in world
war ii became a task of immense scale
and complexity
as again the lesson of military history
was proved the will to win victory must
be matched with the means for achieving
that victory today on the big picture we
will see an account of another massive
logistical effort providing the combat
materiel and services necessary to
support United States Army military
operations and defense of free South
Vietnam
the major part of the supplies and
equipment sent to Vietnam begin their
journey at ports on the west coast of
the United States delivered to the docks
for shipment overseas are all supplies
weapons and facilities necessary to
equip transport and maintain our army on
its Vietnam mission many important
supply items are taken aboard and
specially developed containers to
facilitate loading and unloading
everything from food small arms
ammunition and medical supplies to
helicopters and heavy weapons must be
available in good condition for delivery
to our fighting men
military suppliers that equipment are
brought in to Vietnam through various
ports and landing area major ports are
Saigon Newport
Green yarn
daaang and Cam Ranh Bay material has
moved inland from the ports and coastal
areas to regions closer to the combat
area where support depots are
established with the rapid buildup of US
forces in Vietnam in 1965 Robin port
facilities at Saigon had resulted in a
backlog of as many as 40 ships at a time
waiting in the harbor for a place to
unload
today an extensive port modernization
program has greatly increased the
efficiency of cargo handling cooperation
between the South Vietnamese authorities
and the US Army transportation personnel
has cleared the traffic jam from the
harbor
methods for unloading cargo have been
improved through careful study of
terminal management techniques on Saigon
stocks cargo is shifted quickly and
easily by forklifts because commercial
and ade cargo also arrives at Saigon the
port's facilities are always heavily
burdened over 200,000 tons of military
cargo may be unloaded here in an average
month and an equal amount of commercial
cargo
even with improved port facilities the
movement of cargo through Saigon is
often hampered by traffic in the city's
crowded streets
to help relieve the logistical Burton on
saigon the newport transportation
terminal was built three and a half
miles upstream from the capital four
piers can accommodate heavy cargo
vessels equipment and suppliers arrived
here from various US army depots
but it is at Cam Ranh Bay on the South
China Sea where the full extent of the
United States Army is logistical build
up in Vietnam and be most dramatically
illustrated in 1965 these shores were a
sandy wasteland army engineers were
assigned the job of turning this area
into a major service and supply base
everything had to be built everything
that would be needed for total troops
and combat support a type of docking
area was installed known as they along
pier the device was a large barge like
platform supported on steel pilings
driven into the bottom of the bay
the long piers are in wide you said many
South Vietnam coastal supply points by
late 1966 ad long pier for the handling
of ammunition was completed at Kamran
bein located for safety at the end of a
long causeway the pier is able to handle
a thousand tons of ammunition daily
ammunition arriving from the United
States is moved out as quickly as
possible by land sea and air to the
various combat sector petroleum products
for US army aircraft and vehicles are
handled at specially built facility this
jetty at Cam Ranh Bay and accommodate
large tankers from which Petroleum is
pumped at the rate of over 400,000
gallons an hour a few miles inland a
tank farm stores the petroleum for use
as it is needed
a variety of general support maintenance
units services military equipment the
watchword here is inspect and repair
only as needed
they aim gets the equipment back to its
combat unit with the least possible
delay
what was formerly a sleepy fishing
village has become a dynamic modern port
capable of offloading processing and
transshipping immense quantities of
urgently needed military supplies and
equipment nearly 25% of all the military
logistical supplies coming out of the
country enters here the remarkable
development of supply and service
capabilities at Cameron Bay is typical
of the US Army logistical build-up
throughout South Vietnam
often supplies must be concentrated in
areas where port facilities are either
inadequate or entirely unavailable in
these cases ships anchor off coast and
cargo is unloaded over the side onto
light urns
known as logistical over the shore
operations this method of bringing in
material adds considerable flexibility
to the army supply activity
all major logistical centers are
strategically located for the most
effective distribution of combat and
combat support heightened the extent of
the logistical problem in Vietnam can be
readily understood by a look at the
average military tonnage per month of
key supplies brought into all of South
Vietnam in 1967 45,000 tons of
ammunition 60 million gallons of
petroleum 10 million food rations by far
the greater amount of it coming in by
ship this of course is in addition to
the thousands of tons of general
military cargo including heavy weapons
vehicles and equipment which must be
stored maintained distributed and
serviced how does the army keep track of
this vast input of costly combat
material once at the coastal areas how
do the suppliers actually get to the
troops in the rice paddies and central
highlands of South Vietnam and what
about the many essential logistical
support services so necessary to the
Army's mission the answers to all of
these questions lie in careful planning
and organization of our logistical
facilities in the Pacific until 1967
these facilities at Okinawa headquarters
of the second logistical command were
the marshaling point for Vietnam Bound
military supplies and equipment but
pressing and increased logistical needs
required shipment of the vital combat
material directly to South Vietnam for
more immediate deployment
much of the heavy-duty maintenance on
military equipment is still accomplished
on okinawa an automatic data processing
facility handles requisitions from
combat units in vietnam for supplies
from the continental united states
linked directly to the okinawa command
is the first logistical command at long
Binh South Vietnam here an inventory
control center working in conjunction
with the okinawa base keeps records of
existing supply stocks in vietnam and
determines future needs
the first logistical command is
responsible for the distribution of
combat supplies and equipment coming
into the country for United States and
other free world troops
this is the largest single army troop
command with over 60,000 personnel
trained in supply and maintenance
operations and servicing American and
Allied soldiers throughout Vietnam from
ammunition durations from gasoline to
bridges from medical supplies to housing
the first logistical command supports
the soldier in the field for everything
he needs to sustain him in his combat
mission before setting out in supply
convoys drivers of army trucks are
briefed on possible hazards up ahead
these men carry weapons and know how to
use them should the Vietcong attack the
convoy most supply items moved by truck
from depots to forward support areas as
close as possible to the combat zone
road conditions in Vietnam are not
always equal to the task many combat
areas cannot be reached at all by
vehicular traffic
we're Road access is not available
helicopters touched down on landing pad
and bring in the precious cargo
the Army's heavy-duty helicopter the
ch-47 known as the Chinook and carry
everything from heavy construction
equipment to an entire troop gun
directly to the battlezone
for longer hauls cargo aircraft make the
run from depo to foreign support landing
fields when they are available
each forward support area keeps a
stockpile of all classes of supplies
geared for the particular type of unit
it supports suppliers are kept at levels
necessary to support the speed and
intensity of the unit mission
at all times contact is maintained with
first logistical command headquarters to
make certain that additional material
will be on hand as needed from these
stockpiles close to the battle area
combat units will draw what they need to
continue to fight against the enemy
while much of our troop strength can be
supplied by vehicles and aircraft in the
southern Delta region made up largely of
wetlands logistical support must often
be accomplished by water rooms assault
craft carry the men to battle and the
combat material they need must be
readily available
assault boats barges and other craft are
used on navigable waterways to bring
suppliers and equipment to the man
everything the soldier needs to do his
job goes by water floating firing
platforms are one of many logistical
support facilities that must be provided
for the riverine force
transportation both companies supporting
combat operations in this area have a
wide capability for manoeuvre combat
support River craft are moved wherever
they will best serve the unit mission
maintenance barges can repair army
aircraft and military equipment on the
spot to avoid taking the vitally needed
items out of battle support for army
combat activities is performed by
another important water based facility
the army aircraft maintenance ship
Corpus Christi Bay anchored off the
coast of South Vietnam
the vessel carries the team expertly
trained for every major aircraft
maintenance specialty on rotary or
fixed-wing army aircraft in battle time
is always critical aboard the floating
maintenance ship valuable hours or even
days are saved in repairing equipment
that might otherwise have to be sent the
US bases in the Pacific or back to the
United States for maintenance the
diversified Army forces in Vietnam
require the same capability for skillful
repair in dozens of other army specialty
equipment such as armored vehicles pose
a particular maintenance problem tanks
armored personnel carriers and other
combat vehicles may be disabled not only
as a result of enemy action but from the
rigors of heat humidity and difficult
terrain
literally hundreds of items of essential
combat equipment from the smallest to
the largest must be serviced without
delay and maintained or quickly restored
to combat readiness condition
maintenance is one of the foundations of
logistical support the Army's
maintenance organization provides this
support from field repair close to the
combat zone to the more complete
maintenance capabilities at the larger
logistical bases thorough command and
control along the entire chain of
logistical support assures that
carefully planned combat operations can
go forward uninterrupted and with
greater chance of success those surface
transportation accounts for the major
supply movement in Vietnam airlift is
vitally important in getting essential
repair parts to their destinations at
Kunsan Air Base outside Saigon the red
ball air express operation expedites the
flow of repair parts for military
equipment of every kind like all combat
material red balled inventories are kept
at levels sufficient to meet critical
needs red ball shipments are given high
transportation priority so that badly
needed repair parts may be transshipped
to combat units without delay those
supply and maintenance of troops and
equipment form a cornerstone of the US
Army logistical effort many other
support services are indispensable to
combat operations Army engineers
paved the way for the creation of
logistical facility engineers have
developed new and more effective methods
of clearing jungle regions for
helicopter touchdown zones or landing
strip for army aircraft
a great importance is clearing jungle
growth to reduce the possibility of
ambush in areas where our troops are
conducting combat operations
another method of clearing areas where
the enemy may hide is by defoliation or
chemical spray which inhibits the growth
of foliage
air strips too soft for the weight of
heavy aircraft they have to be prepared
with specially designed synthetic
surfaces
facilities for preparing construction
materials such as concrete or asphalt
are operated by Army engineer
guaranteeing adequate supplies of safe
drinking water for the soldiers is an
important engineer responsibility at
water purification plants continuous
tests are performed on water resources
with combat troops in remote
hard-to-get-to areas often under enemy
fire feeding our troops in Vietnam is a
difficult logistical problem
food is brought in the big black areas
by truck forever possible when Surface
Transportation can't get through food
and water are airlifted in
there's no place to land the child's
airdrop to the combat unit
while engaged in active fighting
soldiers receive combat rations
consisting of complete appetizing meals
which may be eaten hot or cold new
methods of processing and preserving
fresh foods for the troops in the field
are constantly being developed
care for the individual soldier in war
or peace has always been a major concern
of the United States Army in Vietnam
medical evacuation of the wounded may
call for special logistical support and
equipment and operational methods
this rescue hoist mechanism and lift a
wounded soldier out of a jungle region
but the aid of a specially rigged seat
coordination between rescue units and
army hospitals throughout Vietnam
provides quickest possible
transportation of the wounded from the
scene of battle to the nearest medical
facility logistical support for the
fighting man includes providing for his
relaxation as well as his duty
assignments entertainment is often
arranged at base camps and hospitals
provision must be made for
transportation and housing for the
cast's of travelling shows this company
of entertainers stars Martha Raye in a
special performance at the second US
Army surgical hospital in Vietnam
to support the fighting man with latest
technological advances in combat
material is a continuing objective of
army logistics this air mobile firing
platform is being placed by a helicopter
in a flooded rice field
a 105 millimeter howitzers brought in
and positioned on the platform providing
a unique artillery emplacement and
innovation in locating enemy troops as
the airborne personnel detector operated
by men of a chemical detachment the
device is secured to an army aircraft
sensory apparatus on the detector will
signal the presence of the hostile
troops in suspected areas many new
combat support devices and concepts are
tested and proved under actual combat
conditions
inevitably success on the battlefield
depends on total logistical support in
every phase of combat operation whatever
the supplies or services required
wherever they must be available the need
is always urgently the time is always
now an army behind the army the
personnel who backup our fighting men
with supply maintenance and service are
indispensable to our military effort
they are in fact our pipeline to victory
the famous 19th century Prussian
military strategist Karl von Clausewitz
summed up the purpose of army logistics
vividly in his famous series of essays
on war to bring every available man
horse and gun to the battlefield in the
shortest possible time and with the
utmost momentum in terms of our modern
more sophisticated military ways and
means that is what we are doing in
Vietnam today that we are providing
total support for the fighting man is
proven by this significant fact not a
single United States Army combat
operation in Vietnam has ever been
delayed or cancelled for lack of
logistical support